[Music]
put the kid on the kid yeah the kid he's
great what's your name Manuel Manuel
Manuel's great
Manny is our eyes and ears through the
story
the idea was to show what it might be
like to experience Hollywood from an
outsider's point of view
I want to be part of something bigger
bigger than what bigger than this money
is a dreamer he wants to do anything
related to movies
his rise is modeled on the people of
that time who without much experience
happen to be in the right place at the
right time I was wondering if you make
up something for me on the set he's
never been on a film said but the beauty
of Hollywood is that you get to be an
outsider and find your home there she is
a jack of all trades he winds up an
assistant to a movie star good morning
time to go make a movie
and then very quickly it started doing
various work for Studio honchos
what do you think
[Music]
you got those cameras pointed in the
wrong direction
[Music]
he realized that something was about to
explode everything's about to change he
just wanted to be part of it and nothing
is going to get in his way